Rita you you were there for the civil
rights movement absolutely I was there
sitting on the Lincoln monument when dr.
King said I haven't dreamed I was there
there have been numerous protests around
the world combatting police brutality
combating systemic racism how are you
feeling about all of it
angry upset and mostly very frightening
I'm frightened because they're getting
away with a lot of dreadful immoral
illegal unlawful unsympathetic things
and they just have a perfect example I
think that the people who are very
biased about just about everybody but
not didn't even talking about Latinos or
blacks I think those people have been
given permission to let those feelings
out and in a way it's a good thing
because now we really know we really
know where some of our problems lie in
this country I mean it's no longer a
secret that people can't go around
saying oh no come on you just take a few
examples and you can no no no we know we
now know and I think it's done some
wonders for us in the Hispanic and black
community it's official now that we know
where we stand
we always kind of knew but now it's
right there in front of our faces and
that's that's good that's important for
us to and I want to know what have you
learned from watching these these
demonstrations on TV and just kind of
the rise of the black lives matter
movement and seeing what people are
doing out there hi I am thrilled to
death pieces because I see a lot of non
black faces that's very important it's
somehow in the past this these
complaints have been taken as seriously
as they should and I am for what really
really I feel empowered I feel very
excited because I honestly feel that for
the first time truly the first time
things are going to change why do you
feel that way
I feel that way because I see a lot of
people coming together at the worst
possible time with masks on their faces
most of them and I see that people are
really understanding the seriousness of
the problem we've had forever it's as
though we've had a low-grade fever for a
long time and now that fever has really
burst out so I know it's I just know in
my gut I was talking to Whoopi Goldberg
yesterday this is going to be different
what did she say what did you guys talk
about we talked about exactly what I'm
saying right now and we also talked
about the fact that she just loved me in
the king and I which was buried which
was very very nice
she wants the Green Beret person who was
the first person to suggest the knee
kaepernick she wants to interview the
Green Beret who suggested to him and he
taken me so I hope she gets him Rita you
you are someone who has dedicated your
life and your career towards fighting
for the Equality of Latinos and right
now the conversation has shifted to how
white people can be better allies to the
black community and I want to know what
are your tips or takeaways that you can
share because people look to you to set
the example I think they just really
have to listen I think they have to I
think they have to uh become sensitive
to what it is that Hispanics are talking
about all the time with it black
community is talking about all the time
I don't think we've done a good job of
listening
and I think they kind of have to go to a
non-racial school they have to provide
that for themselves to just really have
to listen I can see I can really see of
the eyes of my people for black people
black actors black friends when they get
sensitized to something that's being
said to them what I'm really saying is
that it's important for white people to
understand that we are of necessity
because of all that's happening in our
lives and in our experiences where we
are kind of sensitive and it's
unfortunate but that's how it is at the
moment I don't to ask because you just
brought up your experience this is and I
want to know about personal experiences
that you dealt with as it pertains to
racism when I was in my 60s which now
seems like I was 28
I hadn't done a film in quite a while
and I was very depressed and my agents
finally found a film a script and they
said with a being directed by a very
famous man and who I do not want to name
because it's not what this is about and
and I said wow yeah and it was a
wonderful part was small but it was
really juicy and I couldn't wait to
audition and I worked on the script and
I worked every nuance every word you
know to get it down to what thought was
as perfect as I could do it so I went to
the audition the director was there with
his minions around him and he said and I
said I can't wait to do the same for you
because I I just I just think I have it
I know what to do with this
and he said wonderful and he looked at
my script and there was a sudden
silence and he said and he was English
he said I said excuse me he said no no
no dear he said oh no this is not the
part we wanted to you to try out for is
some mistake
he said we wanted you to try out for the
part of the Mexican whorehouse madam and
I to tell you the blood sort of left and
I hadn't worked now for about two years
in the movie three years the blood just
kind of left my my head and settled in a
pool around my ankles and I want to tell
you that the part of the Mexican
whorehouse madam was two pages and it
was in Spanish and I was being asked to
or even audition try out this part with
three lines in Spanish I couldn't I
didn't know what to do after the blood
came back to my head I said to him yeah
I I'm sorry and I was shaking shaking I
was so humiliated I said I I don't do
Mexican whorehouse fans and he said oh
no no dia that's not what I said he says
no no you don't understand the method
yes I do I do I said you don't
understand and I took my coat and I
deliberately go very slowly got up from
the chair picked up my coat and put my
shoulder back around my shoulder
and very slowly exited the place a plate
of course everybody was like oh my god
yeah I went to my car which was parked
up on below and I had a one hour crying
session myself
it was heartbreaking this is when I was
60 I'd already won and I was thinking I
won the Oscar
I want Emmys I won I won I won I want
how does this happen how does this
happen and I went home with my husband
said how'd it go I said oh it was okay I
don't think I did a very good job he
said huh
he knew me so well yeah and he put me in
his arms and his bro 4head he said Rita
have value you are talented and you're
also Hispanic you have to understand
that and he said you have to get over
that that's how it is for you and that
was 30 years ago
I still get teary-eyed when I think it
it hurts so bad it hurts so bad it's
still with us in that light of firing
you to do everything you could well of
course I'm right my major is to just you
know keep moving this is always what I
tell myself but it still hurts so that
means that some part of me still can't
take it some part of me is still a [ __ ]
and when you a part of you is a [ __ ]
you just have to say to that little girl
in you who still doesn't believe I have
to say to her go to your room
and be brave and that's what I do
obviously I'm tough because I can talk
about it and I think it's important to
talk about it I was in psychotherapy for
eight years trying to solve that problem
as a result of that audition oh no no no
no before that before that this is after
said therapy what compelled what
compelled you to seek therapy in the
first place was that another incident
you guys well no it's the many incidents
I went to therapy
because I felt so valueless and a friend
of mine who really cared for me said you
know what you really need to work this
out with somebody you really need to go
to therapy and even though I'm still
hurting I'm also kind of I mean it's not
that I'm tough it's that I'm resilient
yeah you never get past there's a
defense but you know I think especially
my generation we're now looking we're
not accepting that we're doing
everything we can no it's great we're
holding people accountable we're saying
that that's not acceptable I'm not going
out for that role I will not accept
police treating my friends or my
colleagues like such so are you raising
these concerns what is it that you're
doing to enact all of these years I'm
talking to you and we're talking about
the subject this is what I can do now
I am very hesitant to go out there
because I am I'm about to be 89 in
December and I'm very very alter
cautious because of this virus I miss
doing the physical protests I mean I
brought up on that practically I started
doing that when it was what 18 I think
well yeah I mean Rita you you were there
for the civil rights movement absolutely
I was there I was there ah sitting on
the Lincoln monument when when dr. King
said I hadn't dreamed I was thinner what
do you remember about that Oh everything
I remember everything
I remember we were sitting literally no
more than 15 feet away from dr. King he
was standing there doing a speech not
the I had a dream speech and a wonderful
gospel singer who was very close to him
said said to her I had a dream tell him
about your dream tell him back to dream
and I heard heard him I saw him put away
his speech which was written and start
to talk about I had a dream I'm telling
him I still can't talk about it with
getting these giant poo spots oh you
should see my arms right now and and we
just got so turned on it was so exciting
and I remember looking in back of me and
there were thousands and thousands and
thousands of people and I remember
thinking I think this is gonna be a very
memorable experience Sarita
don't forget one detail of this Wow I
said mr. Sammy Davis jr. and Harry
Belafonte was I think I'm my right and
it was a most extraordinary experience
I've ever had that really activated me
that did it I thought when this many
people I'm not alone I'm not alone in my
hurt and I'm not alone in my fear and
I'm not alone in the belief that this
has to change and then I can be one
little bitty weeny cog in that machine
there's Cubans in an uber right now we
still have no plan changing people's
minds about politics is hard how did you
think it was going to go this is a very
powerful episode of one day at a time I
want to know your reaction when you saw
the subject matter oh I was so real
beyond words it's not fruitful yell at
each other and try to convince each
other of what is right and what it's not
right I think that's very very very
important the alvarez's decide ok they
are our family we still love them we
hate them and we love them and that's
wonderful
we're not different we speak different
languages we like different foods that
doesn't mean that in our heart and heart
we're still human beings you have hearts
the beat we have blood streams we have
blood pressure and and we're not that
different
[Music]